hi again
been a long while since i've done one of
the talk
uh films
i'd like to talk today about um
the aikido that i see in the world
and uh
the one i chose particularly to do was
uh we called it
iwama style aikido under the
leader of cytosensei when he was uh
alive
and he was the caretaker of uh oceans
dojo once uh sensei passed away
and now it's been taken back by the
usher family that
owned the land anyhow and the dojo
and the agreement you may know was that
psychosensity would be the caretaker of
it until he himself passed away
okay so
the majority of
the world is doing what we would class
as honbu style like you know
the more flowing style
and
to me that's a more of a sensitive style
than the iwama like you know the walmart
aikido is perhaps
i don't know it could look more stiff
brutal
um
but it is
a lot more marshall
and i've said on other films that
if we just
could blend them together
and that's what i've been trying to do
for many years in my mind
because to me
it's a body science that we have to
study our own body on how to improve
depending on your level will depend on
your abilities
to quickly change
your body
position now
if i just lift my arm
like this
and you're seeing the camera it's quite
straightforward in front of my face it's
quite straight
that's actually not in a natural
position
the natural position is
here it's if i put it you see it covers
my because i've got big hands it covers
my face
but
this face is slightly open
if we do it this way
then it's more like a cutting blade
and yes you can cut down with it it's
more abrupt more aggressive
they have open hands and they
their sensitivity guides the yuki down
and
in the dojo that's perfectly okay
but i was taught that um in the street
you've done this the person would pull
their arm away
because you're not attached to them
but rather than say
this one's correct that one's not
correct let's have a look at um kombu
style
aikido
and the way
i like the sensitivity of it
because to do this with open hands you
have to have sensitivity
now there was a combination
senses like cuba sensi
uh acai scentsy and many others you'll
see them quite
brutally cutting their ookies down you
know with this hand like they cut it
down fast
and to the point
everybody's aikido works because it's
their aikido
they adopt it to
to make it work with their body
but if you have
this receiving blade here it still
receives it this this will be more of a
block
so it's
them against you if you do it this way
then what happens is if you're
sensitivity is correct it can actually
fold when it hits
when they come together can fold and
then you can just close your grip
and it becomes a natural gripping on
their wrist
or the other hand
can be
naturally
molded
to grip their elbow
so so to me both are correct but the
honbu style akido is more sensitive
and a lot of the uh iwama
people
they're so strict in their mind and
stubborn would say that they're not
looking at flexibility
the flexibility of the mind and and the
science of how we have to change if i
just turn on my chair
and i keep turning on my chair apart
from the noise
and i put this hand out but i turn as i
turn on my chair you see
it becomes flat
so sometimes entering if it if you're
entering xiaomi chi icchio
as long as your body
will
make if this is the central point when
it comes once it comes together
if you move your body around
then the hand doesn't move so much
obviously the fulcrum your body's on a
much larger fulcrum than the
than the hand is
but the hand will
so i'm turning now and i'm turning i'm
turning and turning
so so scent sensitivity and body science
so the body sounds to me
when i was training anywhere
only for a short period but when i was
trying there
i met a third dan
and he was to me the carbon copy of
cytosensei
he looked
exactly
in action and if it was a slight
distance away from you perhaps doing the
weapons in the morning
um
you would actually
need to take a second glance because it
he was so much like santos sensei you
thought that he was him
but what i found by practicing with him
he was more like a marshmallow than her
than a human being
and you find this a lot with the top
senses when you think you've grabbed
them or got them they vanish they all
melt away
and i think over the years we learn what
i call body science
we learn to
move
the
this perhaps into our stomach or our leg
or our back you know we we transfer the
the impact of where the power needs to
be placed and the part that receives
may become very soft
if the person pushes we may withdraw but
we might turn as we withdraw
hence you get
an error equal
when pressure is applied to you
you should absorb
but
a lot of the people
become very stubborn-minded
and they think that they should stay in
control
and not absorb and blend
and i think this is where the biggest
factor in
the iwama practitioners
they don't actually see that sensitivity
is um key to advancement
so
i've said this before if we could blend
the two
so i encourage you all to watch
there's so many films on youtube now
watch both
have an open mind
and watch both styles if you prefer
other styles there's other styles niccio
sensei he used to do more of um iaido
weapon weaponry like you know but for
him he was very precise very exact
um but that's not so popular in the
world in in numbers
whether i call the hombu style like you
know is the the main one and that is
the one that will survive all of them
i'm sure
and
even though i chose
iwama
of thought
even though i chose that it suited my
body
but i've had to look at the other styles
and i choose uh hong mu style to get my
knowledge of how to blend
flow have sensitivity
so
please um look at as many videos you can
because it's your aikido at the end of
the day
you will be the person that um
succeeds and gets closer to our scentsy
and if if that's your goal then
you need to look in all
quarters but
when pushed
move the body to a new place
if if an oncoming vehicle is coming at
you you will step out of the way you
should do the same with a human being
and think if everybody is bigger than
you doesn't matter how big you are just
think consider them as bigger and better
than you
and that way your sensitivity
and your
techniques if they're powerful enough
we'll be able to blend then control them
and and you can neutralize um the attack
in a real situation
because we spend most the time
in the on the tatami rather than out in
the streets looking for fights
we
must be careful we don't get
disillusioned with um thinking that it
will work in the streets because most
aikido won't and even if it does you use
such a
i've had to use it
and you use such a proportion of the
whole technique
that it's such a miniscule amount but as
long as that minuscule amount works
that's the other thing you have to care
care about
but when your adrenaline is running
really high because it does get you
emotionally if somebody starts to build
a build the fight and you realize you
can't neutralize it by talking your way
out of it
your adrenaline will
um
rise as well
and what comes out of it you won't know
until afterwards
and hopefully you'll still be standing
or you will be the standing one
um
and
then your adrenaline will take a long
time to calm down after
but then afterwards so you're about to
consider all the things that
you've done all the actions you've done
okay i hope you've enjoyed this
and
please keep practicing and
above all
when you're not on the mat
think think think with your mind about
aikido and the
ways in which you can
develop it
thanks for your time